Today at the Comfy Mug channel, I am
going to show you how to make this
arcane style skin shader using only
procedural nodes. I'm going to show you
everything for this shader. I'll show
you all of the individual textures. Then
we'll go into the compositing system
because there's a little bit of
compositing going on over here. We're
only going to make this section here and
then connect it to this section as well.
It's a node jungle. Yeah, I'll try to
make it very easy for you guys to
understand. I'll take my time to show
you each individual node and we'll
recreate all of this. For the sake of
streamlining the whole tutorial process,
I pre-recorded myself making the arcane
skin shader off stream. But if you want,
definitely go check out the recorded
VOD, which is free for anyone to watch.
The link is in the description below. I
want to say a quick but heartfelt thank
you to all of my patrons who keep this
channel running for me, especially my
Eldermug members. You guys truly do the
most for making these videos possible.
And speaking of which, all of my
Eldermug and Magic Mug members get this
shader and several variations for free.
So, if you're in one of those tiers, go
ahead and download this shader. The link
is in the description for you as well. I
hope you enjoy. And now, let's dive
right into the tutorial. All right. So,
as I said before, this skin shader is
completely procedural. It reacts to
colored light really well, and you can
also use it with HDRI to get pretty much
any sort of environment that you'd like.
So, really versatile shader. It does
have some compositing actually going
into it, which I will talk about at the
end or closer to the end of the video
here. This is what it looks like without
the compositing. I just disabled the the
compositor there. Uh, usually have it on
always, but I disabled it. So, as we're
building this shader, we are just going
to be uh looking at the viewport without
any sort of compositing. Once again,
this is in the HDRI renderer, but I have
two sunlights set up. One as the main
sunlight uh and and another as the uh
sort of like rim light or or bounce
light in the viewport rendering. This is
how the the shader looks. It is uh
heavily topology based. So, uh, a lot of
this stuff will follow the the normals,
and I'll show you a little bit more on
the way that that works. But I do also
want to cover the fact that this is in
Eevee. Just just keep that in mind. You
can bake these textures though. So, if
you want to uh to bake them and use them
in cycles, that uh works as well. Uh,
and then I do have in the color
management tab, I have the uh view as
standard. The samples are at 25, but I
don't think it makes much of a
difference having the default 16. It's
just personal preference. Uh, and then
also you want to make sure that in your
system preferences you have node
wrangler enabled. So just just check
mark that bad boy and save preferences
and you guys will be all good to go. Now
I'm going to show you real quick what
the uh whole shader looks like. We have
several different components going on
here. So this would be our brush texture
right here which we'll start making
first and then that is all coming into
the uh voronoi which is really driving
the normals and the and the color
differences and and whatnot. And that
actually goes into a couple different
sections. One is the regular output that
actually has all of the the color data
and whatnot. uh as well as some uh rim
lighting and uh what is it called? Not
uh kind subsurface scattering,
artificial subsurface scattering
actually. Uh and then the last portion
is just the glossiness. It's what gives
us that uh nice reflective uh sort of
look. Uh, and with that, I'm not just
going to be showing you guys how to
recreate this uh, these individual
sections, but I'll also be showing you
how to make the skin softer. As you can
see, I went with a little bit harsher of
a tone shift than you would see in the
Arcane Show. The reason why I did this
was just to show you guys how all of the
textures kind of flow and and uh, mesh
together. uh really getting or trying to
emulate that brush texture look without
uh actually having to go in and texture
paint. If you can texture paint, then
that's awesome and you could probably
skip the uh first node group area with
the brush texture, but this is a
completely procedural shader. So, if you
don't know how to texture paint or want
to save some time, then all you need to
do is just build it the way that I've
built it and change some parameters
based on what your preferences are. I am
working on a short film right now or an
animated series I should say. And this
is a part of a bigger character. His
name is Kel Tarus and he is a Ptorian.
So, keep an eye out for that animation
as I continue to release devlogs and the
process of me making this whole thing.
But with that, let's jump straight into
recreating this shader. And we'll break
it down into the four sections. And
we'll just start off by taking a look at
this and recreating almost mirroring
what we have over here. Uh so that we're
not just doing this all blind. So what I
want to start out with are these noise
textures here. So I'm actually going to
just uh press shift A and uh type in
noise texture. There we go. And we'll
bring that up here. And I'm actually
going to change the scale to three for
this one and turn down the roughness.
And then I think I had a little bit of
distortion.
Oh, no. Actually, we're we're all good
with that. So then I'll just duplicate
this with shift D and bring it over on
the Xaxis. And then we're going to
change the scale to 80. And then we'll
connect the factor of the first noise
into the vector of the second noise
texture. And I'll tell you why in a
second here. But for now, we're going to
select both of these and press shift D
and bring it down on the Yaxis. And what
we're doing here is just getting two
separate versions of this sort of uh
texture here. And we want to have this
noise texture as 4D rather than just 3D.
Uh so we'll move up and just change that
to 4D. And then we'll uh move it on the
Waxis or width. I I I don't know what
what it's actually referring to. Uh but
we'll move it a little bit on that to
0.5. And then the scale is still good,
but we are going to change the
distortion to 0.5 as well. And we'll
increase the roughness to.5 on this
noise texture here. Now, that's all nice
and dandy, but we got to be able to see
what we're actually doing here. So, what
I'll want to do is add a voronoi
texture. Bring it right there. And then
we'll add a color ramp. Put it in
between. Connect the color of the
voronoi to the uh factor of the color
ramp. And we'll change the black stops
position to 4 and the white stops
position to 6. With that, I'll also want
to go back over to the Voronoi. We'll
change this to smooth F1. and we'll
we'll actually apply a scale of 35. And
now is probably a good time for me to
let you guys know that I'm actually
using the imperial uh unit system. So,
if you're using the metric system, then
it uh might be a little bit different
scaling, but it'll all end up with a
very similar result. I'm not going based
on the exact numbers. I just want to get
a similar look, an artistic look. That's
what we're really going for here. So you
can always tweak the different
parameters for your own characters based
on the look that you're going for. But
with that, I'll also just want to press
CtrlT on my Voronoi. And we'll bring
that up. And I actually want this to be
the object uh texture coordinate output
there for the mapping node. That just
makes the Voronoi wrap around the model
smoothly. Uh, and we'll also connect the
mapping node to the vector inputs of
both of our first noise textures right
here. And once we've done that, we have
set ourselves up perfectly to add a mix
color node. Bring that up. If you're
using uh earlier versions of Blender,
then this would be the mix RGB node. And
then we'll just take the factor of each
of these last noise textures and plug
them into the A and B inputs. Doesn't
matter which one they're plugged into.
Uh, and then we'll take the color output
of our color ramp over here that's
connected to our Voronoi. And we'll plug
it into the factor of our mix color. And
actually, we'll want to just uh shift D,
duplicate the color ramp, bring it over
on the Xaxis. And now we can press shift
control and then leftclick to actually
see what this is doing on our character.
And you can see we got a lot of
different squiggles over here. Again, uh
this is wrapping around my model
probably differently than it would be
wrapping around your model. It doesn't
have to look like the exact patterns
that you see on here. It just has to
look very similar. Just have those
different lines, brush strokes, all all
of that sort of a thing. And what we're
trying to do is with the uh voronoid
texture over here, uh we're breaking up
the two different brush textures that
are controlling the amounts of brush
hairs as well as the scale or distance
for all of these brush textures. And
we're just mixing between the two uh
based on our color ramp and the and the
voroi here uh through this mix color
node. And so what we want to do for this
character is we don't we don't want it
to uh be a harsh black color for these
darker strokes because all of this is
going to plug into the smoothness of
another voronoi. And anything that is
white is usually at the uh or or having
a value of one is usually at the
smoothest that the voronoi can be. And
then if it's black or having a value of
zero, then it is the uh roughest I guess
you could say that it could be. Uh and
and we don't want the skin to be too
rough. So we'll actually just increase
this uh black color stop to a little bit
lighter of a gray. Uh yeah, that that
should work there. A value of probably
around.3.
If you're really wanting to be nitpicky,
we can do.3 there. That should work
well. And with that, we have completed
the first node group, the brush texture.
Uh, and we can actually put this in a
frame. So, we can press shift P and then
press the F2 button on your keyboard and
then call this
brush texture.
And so now we can move on to the second
and easiest uh node group to make and
that's just this voroi with the vector
transform over here. Uh cool thing about
the vector transform node. You can
actually check out my latest tutorial or
my previous tutorial I should say before
this uh this one came out. Uh this thing
is is really awesome. It'll fix a lot of
your problems for pretty much all of
your shaders. So uh just uh go ahead and
check out that uh video. I probably have
a card that you can click on, but for
now we're just going to add a Voronoi
texture right here. We can bring it just
below. And then we'll also do the good
old CtrlT method to bring up that
mapping and texture coordinate node. And
then we'll change this actually to
normal rather than object. I'll show you
the reason why for that in a second
here. But before we do that, let's
actually change this to smooth F1. And
we'll actually reduce the roughness to
zero. And we'll change the scale to
three. And the randomness is good. And
for the smoothness, we're actually going
to plug in that last color ramp from the
brush texture directly into the
smoothness there. And now if I press
shift control and then leftclick a few
times or a couple times, we can actually
see what's going on with this texture.
Now it is very colorful. It's It's uh
going all over the place, but you can
see how with the uh different divots of
my mesh here, the Voronoi texture is
actually following the topology and the
normals. Uh and that's why we have it
connected to the normals. If we were
just to connect it to the object, then
we would get a much different result. As
you can see, it is not following the
mesh at all. It's just going on its own
sort of adventure. And so we just we
want it to stay on normals. And you can
actually see if I increase the uh scale,
then you'll see where all of those
colors are sort of like stretching over
the place and and uh culminating in in
certain areas um or accumulating, I
should say, culminating. Wow. Uh and and
then if we decrease this, it the texture
begins to become a lot simpler. Um so
you can actually see where certain
colors are sort of congregating. Uh so
we want to keep this at Oh, we want to
keep this at three. And that will uh be
good enough for us to get all the
details that we would need for the
different uh shading and and lighting
effects that we're going to add in a
second here. Uh without making it too
detailed or not detailed enough, what
this texture actually really excels at
and what we're actually going to use it
for is the position output. And what
that is doing is just influencing the
normals. So, we're getting those more
stylized color shifts instead of just
the regular normal shifts that we would
get from just the the normal output,
right? So, the voronoid texture itself
is breaking up the normals to get a more
stylized result. And if you want a
softer look than the harsher skin tone
that we have going on here, or or skin
tone shifts, I could say, then you can
just reduce the gray color stop for this
color ramp here. And we'll actually get
a very similar result uh just just with
a little bit less roughness. And this
would be more akin to what you would see
in Arcane for the male characters. The
female characters are a little bit
different because their skin is a little
bit softer. So, we'll go over how to get
that look at the end of the video. So,
stick around for that. But for now, just
so that we can see in a little bit more
detail what we're doing here, I am going
to keep the gray color stop at 04 for
now, just to have the contrast between
those textures. And actually, what I'm
realizing is
uh I had the compositor on. So, this is
what the textures should look like
without the compositor. It's just a very
subtle difference. As you can see, if I
turn it back on, it has a way of
blending the textures a little bit
differently and a little bit more
interestingly uh to get that stylized
look, but without it, you're you're not
uh losing a whole lot there. It's just a
little bit added stylization
uh which we will go over all of the
compositing uh soon here, so don't
worry. But for now, what I want to do is
uh actually we can move this a little
bit over uh so that we're not
encroaching upon the rest of these. And
so what I want to do now is just add the
vector transform node. This is an
incredible node here. And we are going
to change the convert from uh to object
and change the convert to to world. If
you want to check out a more detailed
tutorial on the way that this node
works, then definitely go check out the
linked tutorial down below in the
description. I recommend you use this
node for pretty much all of your
shaders. It is just that good. But then
we're going to add a diffuse. There we
go. And we are going to set that right
there and connect the normal or the
vector output of our vector transform to
the normal of our diffuse. And now we
can press shift control and leftclick
and we will see exactly what the voroi
texture and all of the textures that we
made is doing to the normals of our
diffuse. And this is just the diffuse as
is. We'll actually increase the uh value
to one there so that it's completely
white. Uh, and so th this is what you
will uh see or or close to to what
you'll see. It'll depend on the model,
but this is the the type of texture that
you're looking for there. And it has all
of the light interaction uh ability
right there. But we're actually going to
lose that with the next step. But don't
worry, we'll regain it in in the the
step afterwards. So, now that we have
this going on, we want to start adding a
little bit of color because this is a
very pale boy. He's looking like Darth
Vader underneath that mask there. But
no, so we're actually going to add a
shader to RGB node. And this is one of
the nodes that is only in Eevee. Uh and
and so that is the reason why if you
want to just bake the uh texture itself,
the the normal, right? Then you can just
connect it like this and then switch
this over to cycles. And well, I have
some other modifiers on there that don't
work in cycles. Uh, but then you'll be
able to just bake this texture as is in
cycles. You just need to make sure that
your model's topology is finished before
you bake any of the textures there.
You'll also want to make sure that your
model is UV unwrapped. There's some
great tutorials out there uh to figure
that out. But you'll then be able to
bring that baked texture into the cycles
engine. I don't know why that was so
hard to say. But anyways, staying in
Eevee, we will just connect the shader
to RGB node there uh with shift control
leftclick once again. And now let's take
a look at the finished shader and and
see exactly what we're doing over here.
I may actually want to just copy and
paste some of these and then uh just
tell you guys how to recreate them over
there. So, I'm just going to press shift
D and bring these over just so that we
can have a visual reference up where
we're actually making this. And now, so
what we want to do is add a new color
ramp. So, we'll connect that there. And
I'm actually going to show you guys the
exact hex code for these colors. Uh you
can copy them from on screen or you can
copy them from what I'm telling you
here. Uh the black color stop will
change to the hex code E2787
EFF. I just color picked some of these
colors from the actual show in Arcane.
So just feel free to take a screenshot
of any of the characters skin tones.
Make sure it's in a well-lit room. Then
just color pick from their lighter and
darker skin tones. But for the lighter
skin tone, we have a hex code of E4 A C9
for FF. And I'm just going to copy and
paste that into the white color stop
there. But we also want to shift this uh
color stop down to 5.5. And I'm actually
going to try to eyeball it and show you
guys what this does on the actual skin
shader. Uh so we have those uh two
tones. They are both lighter tones. Uh
so the shadows will look the same value
as the uh the light there. And now we
want to change the lighter skin tone to
a position of 0.55.
Let me see if I can eyeball it here. Oh,
I was so close.
But that's basically what we're going to
do. Uh 0.55. There we go. And that is
just creating a lot more of a stylized
uh tone shift there. And the reason why
we have the lighter skin tone and the
reason why we have a light skin tone in
the shadow area is because I really want
to push that sort of subsurface
scattering for this character. Uh and I
also want to have different tones
instead of it just being one tone tan.
Uh we want to emulate that sort of like
light passing through the uh edges of
the skin there and seeing a little bit
more saturation of the blood underneath.
YouTube, please don't demonetize me.
This is an animated character here. But
with that, we want to add those shadows
back in. Right? But before we can do
that, we actually want to add a little
bit more subsurface scattering. So in
order to do that, we will add another
mix color there. and we'll connect it
right in front of our color ramp. And
we'll actually change the B input color
to a hex code of 754
FF. And I'll just copy and paste that
here. But we don't want to stop with
just that because right now we just made
our skin texture look a little bit more
bland or like it's in a sunset and we
don't want it to look like that all the
time. So, what we are going to do is add
a Fresnel node. So, I'll just move these
down for a second here. And we'll add in
that Fresnel node here. Fresnel. There
we go. And we'll increase the IUR to 1.6
rather than 1.5. Why? It just looked
better than the default to me. But now,
we'll want to add two other color ramps.
So, we'll go back up here and we can
actually just delete this because we
don't need that reference anymore. And
uh we'll just actually duplicate this
with shift D, bring it down on the
Yaxis. And a little hack for you guys,
if you don't know, you can select the
color ramp and just press backspace on
your keyboard and it'll revert it back
to how it is supposed to look. And now
we can connect the Fresnel node to the
factor of our color ramp. And we'll
increase the black color stops position
to 0.1 just just a little bit more. And
let's actually see what this uh texture
is doing. And so what we're getting here
is this really nice soft looking uh edge
lighting going on here. I use this uh
node for some of my uh previous cell
shader edge light highlights going on
there. Artificial edge light. But we're
not going to use it in the same way.
instead. Uh well, first we'll also want
to uh connect the uh vector output of
our vector transform to the normal of
our Fresnel node there. And now our
Fresnel node has taken on that much more
stylized look to it. Uh which is
beautiful. We love to see it. But we
want to mask out some of these areas. We
don't want to have the edge light on all
of the edges. And so what we're going to
do is I'm going to bring this down just
a little bit on the Yaxis. And we're
going to make this color ramp right here
and connect it to our uh new mix color
there. Uh so we'll just press shift D on
our color ramp here. Bring that up. And
then we will change this uh we'll
actually invert the color ramp. So the
white color stop is at the very end. And
then the black color stop. I believe I
had it at 04. Let me double check that.
Yes, I did. Fantastic. And with that,
we'll also want to make a new mix color
node. Plug that in right there. We'll
change the B input color to black or a
value of zero. And then we'll actually
go up and connect the shader to RGB
color output to the factor of our color
ramp and connect the color result to the
factor of our new mix color node. And
what this is doing is it's actually
softening the edges of our Fresnel node
here. And you can increase the white
color stop to just completely get rid of
whatever's in the shadows. So the
Fresnel edge only appears on what's in
the light. That's up for personal
preference. If you want, that parameter
is there. Uh, but for now, let me show
you how this all integrates back into
the main texture because we're going to
take the result of our mix color and
plug it directly into the factor of the
uh actually skin tone colored mix color.
And now we'll press shift control and
leftclick once again to see what has
happened to our skin shader. And now you
can see if we move around here, we have
a little bit more of those darker edges.
That's it's more like contouring, right?
We can see where in those divots of the
mesh, we have a little bit of an edge
there just to make the model pop a
little bit more at certain angles,
right? So before the contouring there,
we have just the regular skin shader. It
it looks nice, right? But with the
contouring, you can see how just the
divots in the mesh and and the different
line works and and whatnot really begin
to show a lot more clearly, which is
always very cool. And you can always
change this color to a different color
if you want. Right? We can uh increase
the value there to get a little bit
lighter of contouring. Right? It's all
it's all up to personal preference, but
we don't want to jump the gun too soon
because now we want to add back in the
actual color data of the light and
shadows there. And so, in order to do
that, all we need to do is just copy our
diffuse and shader to RGB node and bring
it right over in front of our mix color
and connect that to the color of our
diffuse. and then we'll see exactly what
is going on with the shadows now. And
this is a fatal flaw that I forgot in
this stream before. And the reason why
it looks really weird right now is
because once again, we forgot to plug in
our vector transform. So, we're just
going to plug that into the normal of
the diffuse. And now we are getting the
correct shading and different edges
going on here. Again, this is looking a
little bit more rough, a little bit more
grainy, uh, than we would typically want
it. And that's where the compositing
comes in. It just smooths some of those
things out and gives it a lot more
stylization. But we'll keep without it
for a little bit until we get to the
compositing section. But now, we also
added back in that colored light
interactivity. And just to give you an
idea of how good this shader works with
colored light, we'll just change this to
a much more saturated
uh light here. And just just take a look
at how that just operates so well with
the skin shader. The shader adopts that
color fully. And we can also check out
the differences between different
colored light shifts here. I believe I
have two other lighting. There we go.
Yeah, different colors, different
saturation levels. Uh, and if we want,
we can move some of these around to see
how they kind of like blend together.
And we're not getting weird colors going
on. This is the exact colors of the two
different sunlights, and they're
shifting once again really well
together. You can also see this work
pretty well. If we go back to the HDRI
shading here, and we can play around
with the different HDRIs.
uh and see how that kind of just
interacts with the skin texture. You see
based on this uh HDRI right here, it's
adopting more of that orange saturated
color. And we can uh rotate that around
to see the the difference in in look
there. And so we can change this to
several different HDRIs and see how the
different colored lighting and shadows
works al together, different levels of
harshness. This particularly is my
favorite of all the different HDRIs.
It's much softer and it has more
saturated, a little bit more saturated
colors. Uh, so we get all of that nice
color data uh influencing the more
stylized look of our shader. Just cool
littleformational tips for you guys. But
once we just slap this front portion
into a frame here with shift P once
again and calling this skin tone, we are
just about ready to move on to the final
section of our shader, which is the
glossiness. But before we do that, now
is the perfect time for me to tell you I
have free things for you. I'm giving
away several custom asset packs from the
Comfy Mug Shop to three people who leave
a like on the video, comment something
cool, and who are registered as at least
a free member on my Patreon page so that
I can send you an email with the asset
pack of your choice if you do win. The
winners of this giveaway are picked at
random and their placement determines
the value of the asset pack prize. So,
if you win a single, partial, or full
asset pack, I will send you a lovely
email telling you that you've won, after
which you can tell me which asset pack
you would like from my comfy mug shop
with the proper label, and I will send
the zip file directly to your email. So,
make sure you go enter for a chance to
win an awesome asset pack of your
choosing before the giveaway ends. More
details are linked below, so you can
check that out if you have any
questions. And now let's get back into
the tutorial. All right, so now that
we've made all of this and we've done a
lot of really good work so far, the last
thing that we want to do for the shader
itself is add in the glossiness. And so
I'm actually going to go over to where I
have the glossiness pre-made and we'll
just mirror all of the work that we've
done over here. So at any point you can
just see the exact nodes and parameters
that we're working with. So to start
off, we will add a color ramp. We'll
bring that up. And we'll actually change
the black color stops position to 0.5.
And we'll also want to add a mix color
node once again. And we'll set that
right there. And then we'll connect the
color of our color ramp into the A input
of our mix color and change this color
or value I should say all the way to
one. We'll also want to change the
factor to 04. And now, of course, we
need to add our glossy BSDF and we'll
place that right here. Connect the mix
colors result to the roughness. And
we'll also want to change the color all
the way to a value of one. Once again,
we'll then add a shader to RGB over here
and just connect the glossy BSDF. And
then we'll go ahead and just duplicate
our color ramp and mix color with shift
D and bring it over on the Xaxis right
in front of the shader to RGB. Connect
that like so. And then we will decrease
the black color stops position to 2.
We'll also want to change where the
color ramp connects to the mix color to
the factor. And then we'll change the A
input color all the way to zero. or
having a value of zero. And the B input
color, this is where it gets to
preferences. And I will tell you about
that in a second here. But for now,
we'll just have it roughly at a value of
0.25. And now that we have that, we're
just going to go ahead and bring this
over to our recreation of the shader. We
will connect the color of our original
Voronoi over here to the factor of the
color ramp. This is where that placement
is. If you guys need to see that, it's
this foroi, not this one. And then we
also don't want to forget to connect the
vector transforms vector output to the
normal of our glossy BSDF. And now let's
actually just shift control and click on
this mix color. And now it's it's
looking a lot like a pencil sketch, if
you will. Uh we have all the different
hatching going on. And and this is
exactly what we want out of the
glossiness. We don't want the value of
this last mix color to be white for a
very specific reason because this isn't
just going to be slapped onto our skin
texture just as is. This is actually
going to influence the factor of another
node setup that we will add right below
it. So, what I want to do right now,
we'll zoom in at the very end. And I'll
add a another mix color and place this
right here. Oh, that works. And we'll
actually connect this to the factor of
our mix color. We'll also want to
connect the shader to RGB to the A input
as the uh black or the darkest value
influences the A input and the lightest
value influences the B input. There we
go. And now, just to show you what is
exactly going on in this shader before
we add the last part of that glossiness,
this is our little uh glossy color going
on here. Yeah, you see it? It's pretty
cool. It's got all the different colors,
but we don't want it to have all the
different colors, but just one of those
colors at every given time. We want it
to react to the color of the light. So,
we'll actually move to the back here,
uh, just to to see a little bit of
what's going on. And now what we want to
do is press shift A and add an emission
shader. We'll also add a shader to RGB.
And then we'll duplicate that, bring it
down, and add a diffuse. There we go.
And we'll connect these like you see on
screen there. Bring them a little bit
further down and to the side. And now
we'll add another mix color node. And
what this is going to do, let me
actually zoom in here so you guys can
see a little bit that better. What this
is going to do is it's going to allow
for our emission once we change this to
color. It's going to allow for our
emission, which is connected to the A
input, to be influenced by the
saturation and color values of the
diffuse. Typically with an emission all
you would get is just white, right? Uh
but the diffuse has that color info. So
if we combine the two in a color output,
then you can see we get the color data.
Even though it's very subtle, we get the
color data with an emission shader.
We'll actually want to crank that all
the way up so we can see it much better
now. There we go. That That's what we're
looking for. Uh, and now we can connect
this result uh to the B input of our
final mix color there. And with a shift
control and leftclick, we can see
exactly what this last portion of the
shader has done in allowing our
glossiness to be influenced by the color
of the light without it being the
regular weird looking soft glossiness
that that typically uh has. We want
solid colors for this or or solid blocks
of color and that's what the emission
actually does. Uh, so yeah, that is the
shader for the character for more of a
roughed up character, I should say. If
you want something a little bit softer,
then again, you can soften it by just
decreasing the position of the gray
color stop for our brush ture. and we'll
get something a little bit more uh a
little bit softer, a little bit more
akin to the uh the actual arcane style
going on because they they had a little
bit more soft transitions there. But
another way you can do this, and this is
the way that that I actually really
like. I'm going to keep this at 04. Once
again, another way you can do this is
we'll make a little bit of space in
between here. We want to make sure that
the vector transform is in front. And
now we will search for a mix vector.
We'll place that right in between the
voronoi and vector transform. And now we
can connect the vector output of our
mapping node to the B input of our
vector mix. And so now with the factor
of our vector mix, we're able to just
adjust how little or how much of the
depth of stylized texture you actually
want. I like it a lot at 0.5 just at at
its default. And then uh decreasing the
gray color stop slightly to around 0.25.
I'm surprised I actually just eyeballed
that. And then we'll get a much softer
but still stylized look. It's like baby
skin, right? Baby arcane skin. Oh no. H
don't say baby cane.
That would be going too far. Inside
channel joke if you guys don't know.
Inside joke. And then if we actually
apply the compositing, which I'll show
you guys next, then you guys can really
see how this shader is actually coming
together with that softness, right? Uh,
and this the compositing is mixing a
couple different Kuahara filters as well
as a a sharpen. I'll show you how to do
all of that in a second here, but for
now, you can see how that shift with the
compositing uh doesn't change the
stylization so much. It just affects the
smoothness and the softness of the skin
that you have for your character. Once
again, I think.5 is really great for
female characters. Uh for my characters,
I like to leave it at the roughest you
can go for that battleworn look. He is a
Ptorian after all, the elitist of the
elite and he shows no mercy. But
anyways, now that we have this skin
shader completely done in the shader
editor, we need to add the compositing.
And I'm actually going to let live
stream Christian take over for that
because when we made this compositing
setup, it kind of blew my chat's mind.
One one of these nodes in particular
blew their minds and I want you guys to
get that authentic experience. So take
it away live stream Christian. We have a
little bit more time to get into the
compositing realm. It's not nearly as
monstrous as this. It just has a few
simple things, some techniques that I've
already gone over in previous tutorials.
And one new technique that I will show
you guys right now. If we go into our
view layer properties, we have all of
these different things that we can
enable for our compositing. Normally it
our our render layers node for the
compositing and you do have to enable
the use node setup when you get into the
compositing editor here. But normally
you'll just have the image alpha and
maybe depth outputs, but you won't have
mist or position or any of this stuff.
You don't really need any of the rest of
these outputs, but you do need their
innate data for the cryptomat here. It
is very important to the arcane
skin shader. And I'll show you guys why.
If I enable compositing once again, you
can see that my character,
the way that the Kuahara filter works is
if I zoom out more and more, it will
simplify the shader. It will not get all
muddled with all of the detail like it
would with the compositing disabled.
It'll simplify it as I move further out.
And then as I move further in, the
Kuahara filter reenables that detail,
but smooths it over and gives it more of
the painterly aesthetic. However,
without the cryptomat, it would just
look like, and let me make sure that I
have it. So, this would be my basic
setup. There we go. So this koohara
filter setup would usually be my basic
setup for a full scene, right? But the
unfortunate part to that,
and I'll show you here with the viewer,
is that you can see that the silhouette
of the character gets muddled the
further I go out. Right? And I have this
very exaggerated, but it does affect the
silhouette so that the finer details
like the eyes aren't actually seen as
you move further and further out. So I
want to preserve the sharpness of the
silhouette of the mesh itself while
having the painterly look of the base
texture and mesh. And so what we'll need
to do in the view layer properties is
we'll need to just scroll down here and
go into our cryptomat section and enable
object and material. What this does is
it allows you to use the cryptomat node.
And with this, you can choose between if
you want it to identify objects or
specific materials or shaders so that
any object with a specific shader will
always have a particular compositing
setup that's independent from the other
compositing like world compositing and
things like that. So you can have
different levels of kuahara, different
levels of sharpness and even Oh wait,
that's the eye compositing. This this is
the skin compositing. There we go. So
levels of sharpness, right? I'm
sharpening it or I'm softening the
compositing or even different effects,
right? and it'll just affect that
particular
material while keeping the other
materials or other objects that you
don't want this effect to be on staying
clear and not having that effect. This
is how you can do certain like
spiderverse effects with the chromatic
aberration and things like that if you
wanted to do it that way. And so that
that's just how you isolate the
different different things. So the major
thing that we'll want to do is have the
image output from our render layers
connected to the image of the cryptomat
here, right? And we won't use the image
output. We'll use the mat output output
for this so that any character with this
particular skin shader will be able to
have this particular compositing style.
It's not limited to just individual
characters and objects. And you won't
have to remake this thing for each
character. It's it's it's just always
going to be there for that material. So,
we'll go with material and then we'll
press this plus button and then we'll
just select Oh, wait. I think I have to
type it in here. Ah, okay. So, disabling
the inverted hole outline will allow you
to pick your actual base shader. Right.
So now we have this where I'll get rid
of the material again and show you guys
what it looks like from the perspective
of the cryptomat. Just on the mat
output, everything will be a black mask
basically until you select the material.
And then whatever is white is the
material that is selected. And you can
actually select multiple materials from
this. So if I add another cube and give
it a completely different shader, you
can add that into this specific
compositing mat and have multiple
different materials within the same mat
or mask basically for your compositing
setup. It's really versatile, really
easy to use there. But this is what
it'll look like with the cryptomat.
We'll just plug that in. It'll be
plugged in later is what it's looking
like. So now we can just add our regular
Kuahara filter base. And we want one
anotropic. And then we want to duplicate
this and have the other one as classic.
And then we'll just plug in the image
input from our render layer there. And
then we'll just have another mix color.
plug the image input of our anosotropic
kuahara on the A input and the classic
to the B input and then this will be I
think at like 02 and now right now this
is the result that we're getting right
it's a little bit blurriier it's
defining a more painterly look but not
not too
distinct right it's still pretty blurry
we can move back down and what I
actually did to sharpen things up a a
little bit. Oh, I had it at at 0.1.
Okay. So, all all of this up is all this
these factors and and different things
are up for variation and for you guys to
adjust it how you will. I'm going to
zoom in so that we can see the effects
of this more clearly. But we're going to
then add a filter node and connect it
right there. And this filter node has
all sorts of different effects. It
starts off at soften, but then it has
box sharpen, which is like making it
really sharp and pixelated. And then we
have diamond sharpen, which makes it
less pixelated, but still is pretty
sharp. This is what I use. But then it
has all of these different modes which
can be used to create really interesting
effects. And that's the the shadow
effect. But we're going to use a
sharpen. And we'll put this at I believe
it's at 02. So the difference is without
it and with it. It's very subtle, but it
does the trick for how we need this to
look here. Oh, okay. I was looking at
the wrong compositing there. We need the
size for the Kuahar filter to to be four
for both the anotropic and the classic
there. So let me just increase that to
four here. Four here. The reason why I
have both the anotrophic and the classic
Kuahara filter is that the anotrophic
it's just giving it that more simplified
look, but then the classic gives it like
this boxy canvasy look to it. And we
want both to be implemented there. And
you can adjust how much of each one you
want based on this color ramp here. And
then what we're going to do is we're
going to mix in our cryptomat here into
a regular mix color there. So we'll just
add another mix color or we can just
duplicate this actually. And then we'll
connect the mat to the result of our mix
color. And what we really want is to
have the type of compositing that we
want for our skin texture or whatever
shader we're or material we're using to
be in the B input, which makes it so
that everything else is on a different
compositing layer basically. It's like
adding another layer in in Photoshop.
And so now we can I'll add a a cube
again and I'll bring this behind him. So
now what we're going to do is we're just
going to duplicate our regular Kuahara
filter setup here with shift control D
to keep its connections. And then we'll
connect the result of that to the A
input. And now I'm really going to
increase the the craziness of that
compositing. Right? So you can see that
it's on a completely different layer.
And I think that having the inverted
hole method actually helps with the
sharpness there, but it's on a
completely different compositing layer
than our actual skin shader is. So you
can have all sorts of really cool and
really strange effects that shift
between one style and another. And we do
have a little bit of spilling from our
skin texture into the other compositing
layer. But what is really good to note
is that we've kept the sharpness of the
mesh, which is exactly what we needed to
accomplish. And now you can get crazy
with your bad self if you want to. I
like to keep this at like a five for the
rest of my world compositing and just
have this at 2 or between 2 and 4. So,
it doesn't have much spilling, but it's
going to look a little bit more
painterly and a little bit more
stylized, the backgrounds will, than the
actual characters will, which is how
Arcane how you would do the Arcane style
or even the anime style in Blender. How
you would adapt that all to Blender
system is to have them on different
compositing layers, the characters from
the background and give them different
compositing styles, slightly different
compositing styles and having the
backgrounds being more stylized than
characters themselves. And then if you
want to add more cryptomats, then what
you would do is just let me make sure
that I'm adding all this correctly in is
you would have another cryptomat layer.
So we'll just shift control D and
duplicate this and bring it down. Right?
So you would have another cryptomat
layer. Um and you would just add another
mix color at the end. So I'm going to
give our cube a new material now. And
I'm going to make this a really really
distinct color. And then I will make
another cube and disable that there so
it doesn't have a shader. So now what
you would do is for this new cryptomat
thing if you want a completely different
effect than what's on your skin shaders
compositing and what's on your regular
world compositing is you would first get
rid of the well actually I can just
delete this and add a new cryptomat.
That would actually be a lot easier to
do so that I don't have to manually
delete all of the shaders that we added
to it. So now what you would do is
select the new Oh wait, we don't want
the cube, we want the material. We would
select this shader, this material, and
do the same thing that we did over here
with how the cryptomat is connected,
right? But we would add it to I believe
we would add it to this final mix now.
So now we're just affecting that one
cube's material. And then we can add
whatever kind of effect we want that
cube to have. And we can actually add a
color ramp into here. And we can affect
the cubes shading and all of that
directly as well as the color and give
it different shades and things like
that. make it really really dynamic so
that it's just on another layer and we
can increase all of this stuff so that
it's on a completely different layer
than the world compositing as well. I
hope all of that makes sense. But that
is all the core elements to how all of
this would work and I hope that it just
opens up a lot more possibilities for
you guys and your creations there. Thank
you so much for watching all the way
through my tutorial. Remember to leave a
like on the video if you want more
tutorials like this. And also make sure
you enter the giveaway before it's too
late. I'd love for you to chance to win
something for free. But if you want to
see a breakdown of the stone shader
inspired by Arcane that I have for my
Ptorians armor, then you can check out
this video right here.